I'm really pleased to have this
opportunity today to share with you some
of the experiences I gained in the
laboratory and helping customers here at
camp troubleshoot their ICC experiments
and today's presentation is going to be
an introduction to ICC principles and
troubleshooting so how do we define
immuno site chemistry so we would
classify it as an antibody staining
technique that's used to study protein
expression and localization in culture
cells it's very widely used in basic and
clinical research now many of our
customers are using this researchers use
cell lines and ICC or many use primary
cells as well
usually in ICC researchers use
fluorescent conjugates for detection so
today I'm going to be focusing mainly on
immunofluorescence through today's
presentation I'm going to be talking
about the following things so we're
going to talk about selecting the
correct cell line and culturing the
cells which is very important to make
sure that you have a good sample we're
going to take a step by step look at the
ICC AF procedure itself going to take a
brief look at how fluorescence works
we're going to take a look at some of
the results and examples show different
cellular localization because this is
one of the main advantages of immunity
chemistry going to take a look at some
considerations to take you to account
when you don't doing double
immunostaining and I'm going take a look
at some troubleshooting and with in labs
I'm going to include some considerations
for a recombinant protein detection and
then I'm going to hand over to my
colleague Augustin who will take you
through some of our protocol resources
so to begin with what's the main
advantage of immunity kamas tree as I
mentioned the main advantage is that you
can visualize the precise cellular
localization of your target and even
co-localization if you're doing double
staining or
or multiple targets feigning the
advantages that Sunline samples are
often easier to access and tissue
samples so it's easier to get your cell
line to stain rather than waiting for
some tissue you can also affect test the
affected drugs and such as Michigan's
inhibitors and stimulators on the
protein expression and localization in
the cell culture and you can of course
assess the recombinant protein
expression and localization so let's
start with selecting the correct cell
line and culturing the cells so to begin
with you need to ensure that you have a
good positive control cell lines that
you know expresses the protein and the
way to do this is you can either do a
literature search or you can take a look
on the manufacturers datasheet to see if
they've used the antibody you know in
another cell line that's that's been
successful when you're actually
culturing the cells are several things
you need to take into consideration you
need to ensure that you using the
correct Culture Media and this
information you can find again on the
manufacturers instructions all the
suppliers instructions they'll be able
to tell you which is a correct culture
media to use you may also find that the
cells requires some sort of stimulant
messaging or some sort of other agent to
induce the expression of the protein
that you're interested in or perhaps you
may want to study the inhibition of your
protein by some agents so you need to
consider what concentration do you need
to use this agent at or you may need to
try arrange again you could start by a
literature search to find out if there's
any information to start with
in preparing yourself you can grow your
sales on sterile coverslips in a
six-mile culture dish or they retain the
slide available which makes staining of
the south on the slide very easy
afterwards the alternative to this is
for suspension cells where you would
need to culture them as normal and then
you can start to spin the cells on some
slides you capture the fails to the
desired density usually this is about 70
to 80 percent confluent and this usually
takes about 24 to 48 hours you would
then wash yourself carefully two or
three times with PBS
you can then fix the cells and go on to
your antibody staining when do you know
when your cells are ready to stain so
this depends on several factors
so although we say that the cells should
be about 70 to 80 percent of confluent
this does very much depend on the target
some cells need to be really very
confident before they start expressing
the protein you're looking for in the
correct localization so you may find
that this needs to be optimized if your
cells to under confluent they may not
have expressed enough protein yet
[Music]
presentation
if it's a boat compliment you may not
have been biased out in the culture and
it's put a picture with your same
results also we're pretty can degrade
organizations so as I was mentioning you
may need to grow yourself on a matrix
for example on collagen one to induce
the expression of the protein you're
looking for in the Krait localization
i've ever suggested check the literature
to make sure that this is or isn't
required moving on we're going to take a
further look here at inducing or
inhibiting your protein expression so if
you want to induce or inhibit your
protein expression there are various
things that may need to be optimized you
will need to give time for the induction
or in efficient to work and you will
need to optimize the amount of inducing
component as well we have an example
image here so on the right you can see
some heal ourselves that have been
treated with straw restoring to induce
apoptosis and you can see here staining
of caspase-3 which is activated during
apoptosis compared to the control image
on the left hand side you can see that
the control has very little caspase-3 so
you really can't see the effect of the
Storace boring and induction on
apoptosis on the caspase-3 expression
links are going to take a look at the
ICC if' procedure itself so to take you
through the procedure briefly first of
all you would need to fix the cells you
may then need to premiere blight
yourself the cytoplasmic or nuclear
proteins you'll need a blocking step a
primary antibody incubation a secondary
antibody incubation and then of course
you will need to mount and store your
slides and you may like to nuclear
counter stain so let's begin with
fixation fixation is required to
preserve the cells to preserve their
morphology in their composition and to
keep the target in a good condition and
at the correct localization there's two
main ways in which you can do this you
can do para formaldehydes
cross-linking fixation or you can use
organic solvents for PFN fixation we
would recommend to fix in four percent
PFA for ten minutes only this is quite a
short fixation time but there may still
be some cross-linking your protein so
it's not suitable for all epitopes for
organic solvents such as acetone
methanol and ethanol you need to use
these are ice cold temperature again for
five to ten minutes only and you need to
consider that they can affect the
structure of proteins and affect the
epitope of the antibody and they will
also permeable isocell so we wouldn't
recommend you using for membrane protein
detection in normal circumstances
so once you fix yourself you may want to
store them for a while before you
continue with the staining so in order
to do this you would need to drive the
coverslip in the sails completely place
them in a slide box or wrap them gently
in falsehood that they're protected from
the light keep them at four degrees we
would recommend to keep them up to two
to four weeks not really any longer than
this before the staining and then when
you're ready to stain you can rehydrate
the samples in PBS before proceeding
with the protocol and for that you need
to start with blocking steps so the
blocking strap is there in order the
blocking step is there in order to
minimize the background staining from
any protein antibody interactions these
are not specific to antibody antigen
binding so any nonspecific binding
you're trying to eliminate there are
various blocking agents you can use the
serum BSA milk casein gelatin there are
some others as well and we would
recommend to use 5 to 10 percent
blocking agent but ICC it's usually
serum or BSA that's used and we would
recommend to use the same blocking agent
throughout the entire experiment and not
to change between them you can dilute
the blocking agent in PBS or TBS and
blocking can be from 20 minutes to 1
hour and again you may find that
requires some optimization after this
step you can wash the cells three times
for five minutes
in PPS containing Northpoint 2 percent
between detergent
next if you require it you would need to
do some permeabilization the
permeabilization is only needed for
nuclear and cytoplasmic proteins
sometimes you may need to consider it
for membrane proteins that have an
epitope on the cytoplasmic side of the
membrane and if you need more
information you can contact our
scientific support team if you need more
information about particular antibody
that you're using there's couple of
methods form permeabilization you can
fix in organic solvent and this will
pair me bribed yourself or you could use
low point one to not point two percent
triton detergent for ten minutes
Triton is quite a strong detergent and
we recommend it to use it for much
longer than 10 minutes you could then
continue to use a gentle detergent right
between in the rest of the buffers such
as the blocking buffer or the antibody
dilution buffers and this will just help
keep the cells permeable iced and when
you're washing it also helps to wash
away any excess antibody so that's
permeabilization and then you're ready
for the primary antibody intubation so
you would only transport in PBS or TBS
buffer containing 0.2% tween these are
known as PB s T or TBS D you can recipes
for these up on the Internet
we would recommend to incubate overnight
at 4 degrees once or two hours at room
temperatures just very often work but
usually the staining can be more
specific if you intubate overnight at 4
degrees the optimal concentration of the
antibody will need to be determined
there will be some recommendations on
manufacturer data sheets but you may
find that you need further optimization
from there and the aim is really to
optimize ation is really to contain the
most contrast between a specific signal
and any background staining that you
have and use of a positive and negative
control can really help there
after this stuff again used wash the
cells sometimes primary antibodies are
already conjugated in which case you
won't need a secondary antibody but if
you do need a conjugate a secondary
antibody then this would be your next
step so the secondary antibody would
probably be conjugated to a flora Chrome
and we have many of these available
there's many on the market now and the
most common for example are FITC pike
urethra and PE Texas red and there are
many others as well as with the primary
antibody we would recommend to dilute
these in PBS or TBS containing tween and
pact a blocking agent is necessary this
incubation can be from 30 minutes to 1
hour possibly longer again this will
need to be optimized and it can be done
at room temperature so again your
dilution will also need to be optimized
after this step again another wash so
once you finish your staining you will
then want to mount this life and so
covering the cells with the glass on the
slide it will help preserve the sample
keep the cells safe and it protects and
it also improves the optics when you're
looking at it through the microscope if
you're you are using immunofluorescence
there are some special mountains
containing fluorescent anti-fade
available and these help protect against
photo bleaching for when you're storing
the slides as well as for when you're
viewing them many of these special
mountains already contain nuclear
campaigns such as P I and bappy we have
many of these that upcam for example we
have floor shield and bright mounts and
if you want to try some I can recommend
getting these up on the website so once
you manage a slice we'd recommend store
them at 4 degrees in the dark to protect
some photobleaching the frightens may
last up to 2 to 3 weeks or longer but
for
good results we would say to take a look
at them as soon as possible under the
microscope and always be aware of any
photobleaching where you're observing
and imaging the samples before we leave
the procedure I just wanted to you
mention an unusual tip to you and that
is to use antigen retrieval which can
sometimes be beneficial
now antigen retrieval is most commonly
used of course in immunohistochemistry
on paraffin-embedded sections and the
unseen retrieval used to break the cross
links that a place thereby the Paris
maldehyde and this means that the
epitope becomes more accessible to the
antibody so it's not the technique that
he or part of the procedure that usually
used in immunization chemistry however
from some data we have we know that it
can sometimes be necessary to get the
optimal results so we would say that if
other optimizations been tried and the
results still unsatisfactory
particularly if you're not getting any
staining then you can consider including
the step one we tried in some of our
laboratories are to apply heat at 95
degrees in 100 millimolar twists with 5%
urea and has a pH of 9.5 and keep it
that temperature of 10 minutes this
means that the proteins are then
sufficiently denatured and the antibody
binding sites are then more accessible
now you can also check information
provided on the datasheet so very often
if we're aware that antigen retrieval
will help when this information will be
on our data sheets for example we have
ATP v f1 antibody and example shown here
so we have staining of hdfn cells and
you can see that without antigen
retrieval in the image on the left you
can see very little red specific
staining and if we try answering
retrieval obviously this seems to
improve the staining and
and what he has more access to the
epitope and improve the results next I
want to talk briefly about
immunofluorescence how does this work so
there are many for our crowns available
as I've already mentioned each one of
those will have its own unique spectra
for absorption and emission I've got a
couple of examples here for PE and for
sci-fi the excitation wavelength is the
signature wavelength to which the
molecule is excited so this is the
wavelengths at which you shine the laser
the emission wavelength is the signature
wavelength at which that flora chrome
emits a photon so that's the wavelength
at which you will detect so how does
that work so if you have a laser that
specific excitation wavelength it will
hit an electron that's in resting state
within the flora chrome that electron
absorb the energy from that photon and
jumped up to a higher energy level state
it can't keep up that energy level state
and eventually and quite quickly that
electron will lose the energy and drop
back down to its resting state in doing
that it releases any excess energy in
the form of a photon and that is
fluorescence that is what you are
detecting so I'd like to show you some
examples now as I mentioned before the
great advantage of ICC is that you can
get very good contrast and resolution
within your image and it's really easy
to see good cellular localization of
your protein so here we have some
examples so on the top we have some
psychic carotene staining of bovine of
filial cells and we can see the
cytoskeleton stained here particularly
in the image on the left you can see how
well that stained in is very clear the
next image dance we've got to Boleyn
staining which shows up the mic
Gables in martini dividing cells next we
have some new clear examples so the top
image here is from opt for staining opt
for is well known to be a nuclear
protein and you can see the green
nuclear staining there quite clearly
more specific than that
ki67 which is a proliferation market a
cell proliferation marker is known to be
within the actual nucleolar itself so
you can see here the specific staining
in the nucleoli the next image we have
some more nuclear examples we have an
antibody for detection of nuclear pore
complex protein and you can see really
clearly that around the nuclear here
we've got green staining of this protein
the lower image is from histone h3
phospho FM and this was kindly provided
by Professor Brian Turner from the
University of Birmingham and beautifully
shows the chromosomes during mitosis and
all that's doing is picking up this
histone this phosphorylated histone on
the chromosomes during my my taste there
this fantastic image next a couple of
membrane sample examples and here we
have two membrane junction proteins so
at the top we have cloud in five you can
see the lovely green staining of the
membrane and at the bottom we have a
panic is here in antibody here we have
some staining some organelles so at the
top we have staining of lysosomes the
lamp one protein is a good lysosome
marker and you can see the punctate
speckle staining of the lysosomes within
this cell the next one down is staining
my country with complex one breaking and
you can see the green green staining of
the mitochondria three sir
last couple of examples here we have
some lovely cardiac myosin filament
staining at the top and then we have
some the next one down is 58 killer
double from the Golgi protein so in the
green staining in this image you can
really see the Golgi lit up green around
the side of the nucleus so that's some
examples I'd like now to talk briefly
about double immunostaining because many
of our customers use this technique so
what are the advantages of W
immunostaining when you have to
reference as I said before thoracic
detection it's really good resolution in
contrast those really lends itself to
multiple stains within a single cell
line and you can observe the
localization in Co localization of two
to three or more targets and really
you're just limited by the Florek range
that you can use and the fluorescent
microscope that you have so at the
bottom here there's a couple of images
that you've already seen just to show
again so on the Left we have opted for
staining in green and acting in red and
then we had to fly to carotene image
here but cytokeratin is in green and the
actin is in red and you really can see
the difference and localization of those
proteins in this way so when you're both
doing double amines then what sort of
things do you need to take into
consideration so for each of the target
protein you need to use a for a chrome
which emits at different wavelengths so
that they're distinguishable from each
other it's 15 you've conjugated primary
antibodies if possible if not you can
use conjugates of secondary antibodies
in which case you'll need to select
primary antibodies from different host
species or they have these different
isotype subtypes for example igg1 IgG 2a
and again this will ensure that
different target proteins are
distinguishable you'll need to optimize
the procedure for each primary antibody
individually before you put me together
and we really would recommend to do
just to make sure that the reagents are
working well and that the procedures
working well and now the last section I
just like to take you through some
troubleshooting so there's three main
problems you can get in icc perhaps you
might have no signal at all in your
sample you might have high background
with lots of fluorescence or you may
perhaps have an incorrect signal or so
in yourself but it's not at the
localization that you're expecting what
can we do about these so if he has no
signal it indicates the start with a
need to optimise the protocol you might
have a defective antibody or there may
be a lack of target and sample and you
could check that with a literature
search to see how much target should be
there so the type of things that we
would recommend are to increase the
antibody concentration and to make sure
you incubate overnight at 4 degrees so
increasing that concentration should
mean increasing our sustaining there
remember to permeable eyes if it's a
cytoplasmic or nuclear protein
don't let the cell throw out during the
antibody staining this can give patchy
staining so some areas might have no
staining whereas other areas have too
much staining make sure you've had the
correct culture conditions of the cells
for expression of the protein and again
you can check the literature for this
it's always good to include a known
endogenous positive control and this
again will indicate if your procedures
working well ensure the correct a
secondary antibody is being used and ask
yourself if it's working well with other
primary antibodies just to make sure
it's working well for you so we move on
to high background so if you have high
background it's usually from excessive
antibody or autofluorescence maybe or
from nonspecific finding so for this you
need to do the opposite in the way so
you need to reduce the antibody
concentration
make sure you intubating overnight at 4
degree
ensure that your including wash steps
wash three to four times for five
minutes at each wash there and make sure
you include a mild detergent like not
point two percent between in the wash
buffer and antibody dilution buffer
again you want to check that you have
the correct culture conditions and that
the cells will not pose a confluent
ensure there's permeabilization is it
cytoplasmic or nuclear target that
sounds quite counterintuitive but I have
found from my own experience and
experience of our customers that if
permeabilization isn't done when it's
required perhaps for a nuclear target
for example but you don't get most
aiming you may actually get a lot of
excess staining for some reason so just
make sure you've heard me black if you
need to again to check the secondary
antibody make sure that it's not binding
on specifically by including and no
primary control sometimes aggregates of
the conjugated secondary antibody can
give us or the speckled appearance
within the within the sample so you can
mix the antibody well before you use if
you want to you could even filter the
antibody solution before you use it if
necessary sometimes are quite also
fluorescent you may want to check the
literature for this but they may also be
autofluorescence only as a certain
wavelength so if you choose a different
conjugate and view at a different
wavelength you may find that you correct
that problem some cell culture matrix
components and proteins again can be
quite auto fluorescent and again perhaps
you could change the conjugate that
you're using to view into different
wavelengths
and the next problem is if you have an
interesting smell and this really is the
most difficult one to troubleshoot
because usually it shows a like a
specificity for the protein of interest
you can't always be solved by protocol
modifications however there are some
things that you can consider you can
ensure that the permeabilization if it's
a cytoplasmic or nuclear target you can
check the literature for further details
on the localization in that particular
cell type you're using czech is the
culture culture condition to correct for
the expression and that the and for the
correct localization of the proteins or
any other special conditions required
check the secondary antibody again with
a no primary control just to make sure
that it's not binding on specifically if
you want to take it a step further you
could check your sample with a Western
blot and check that the band observed is
at the correct size for your protein the
last piece of troubleshooting I wanted
to look at was considerations for a
confident protein detection many of our
customers are actually detecting
recombinant proteins and there are some
inherent difficulties with detection of
recombinant proteins that are worth
considering before you start your
experiments it's good to confirm it's a
protein that you can selectively
actually phalanx and to make sure
including human agency crimps and if
you're not sure of this if you perhaps
not sure that the immunogen sequence and
you can contact our scientific support
team and will be able to help you with
that you can contact us at technical at
uh become calm
also many recombinant proteins are
tagged sometimes a pair can prevent the
access of the antibody to the epitope so
we would recommend to place a tarragon
the seal
n-terminus just to avoid disruptions
epitopes as much as possible you may
want to assess the stability of
transfection
by other methods for example by rt-pcr
you may find that your translation
method requires more of my day
so it's worth going through that again
and it's very important to include an
endogenous positive control sample and
an endogenous negative control that
really will show you whether it's the
translation that's a problem and if you
want examples of positive and negative
controls you can have a look at
individual and forty data sheets for
some examples so that concludes my
presentation
just to confirm some of the things we've
gone through today ICC is has many
advantages it's a fantastic technique
for looking at the localization of cells
and you can also check the effect of any
treatments on the cells very useful
detection of co-localization for
different targets because of the high
resolution there are many flora craned
available now which make it a very
flexible technique for double staining
useful detection of recombinant proteins
which is usually expressed in the cell
culture the important things are to
ensure the correct culture conditions
and protocol optimization and these
really are the key to success and you
always remember to include suitable
endogenous positive and negative control
cell lines I hope that's been used for
10 years I'm sure your questions have
been coming in through the presentation
and I'll be taking a look at those now
and we'll be able to answer some of
those shortly those we don't get around
to our scientific support team will be
able to get back to use in the next few
days with an answer I going to pass you
back over to Augustin now she's going to
take you some boats through some of our
protocol resources
Thank You Kate for an interesting and
informative presentation I'm now going
to give a brief overview of some of the
products and resources that will be
useful for your research I'd like to
start with introducing our site I paint
a range of products which are an ideal
tool for quick and vibrant subcellular
staining slicer painter kits contain all
components you'd need to stay in
subcellular structures such as actin
filaments mitochondria or lysosomes
actin filaments can can be easily
detected on fixed cells or tissues in
the image shown you can see the labeled
actin filaments in red on HeLa cells
fixed with formaldehyde if you're
interested in staining mitochondrial or
lysosomal structures we also have the
right tool for this our mitochondrial
and lysosomal dyes or stained
mitochondria and lysosomes respectively
in life cells in the image shown you can
see the cellular mitochondria in green
if you want to know more about our site
a painter for Ranger products please
visit the URL shown our fluorescent
imaging dyes are another range of
products you'll find useful in your
research a range of imaging dyes
includes drag 5 track 7 and sigh track
orange drag 5 is a small molecule dye
which labels live or fixed cells
it's afar red dye that only labels
double-stranded nuclear DNA eliminating
the need for RNAs this makes a rapid
alternative to daffy or hoist as a
counter stain for short experiments in
the image shown HeLa cells were stained
with lamin b1 an alpha tubulin antibody
track 5 was added to the secondary
antibody mixture to label nuclear DNA
track 7 is a small molecule dye that
only labels dead and permeable eyes
cells and do to better spectral
properties it's an ideal alternative to
probe a DM iodide
in particular it's a useful tool for
cytotoxicity and apoptosis assays so I
track orange is a dye that stains both
the nucleus and cytoplasm in live or
fixed cells and can be used for cell
segmentation in high content screening
and exploring cell signaling and morph
morphology
all of these biological dyes can be used
in the number of different applications
and in addition to offering low
photobleaching they're compatible with
other labels so you can use them for
multi color analysis you can find more
information about these dyes on the
resource page shown AB AB Kemp catalog
includes over 2500 secondary antibodies
conjugated to biotin enzymes and
different fluorophores which would be
useful for your research
if cross reactivity of the secondary
antibodies with endogenous
immunoglobulins is a concern for example
when the sample tissue is extremely rich
in it immunoglobulins we recommend using
one of our pre absorbed antibodies which
are available as pre absorbed against up
to three or eight species should
specificity of your secondary antibody
be an issue
we recommend using one of our SC
specific antibodies in contrast the
secondary antibodies recognized
recognizing the heavy and light chain FC
secondaries only bind to the heavy chain
of the primary antibody for example the
goat anti-mouse IgG heavy and light
chain antibody could potentially bind
the light chains of other Mouse
immunoglobulins than IgG this risk is
abolished when using a goat anti-mouse
IG GFC secondary all of the pre absorbed
secondaries and different secondary
antibody formats are available with a
number of different conjugates as shown
to help you finding the right secondary
you can use the results shown to help
you select the right secondary
if you have any scientific or technical
queries are knowledgeable scientific
support support team would be very happy
to assist our support service is
available in a range of languages
including Chinese Japanese French
Spanish and German for customers in the
Americas please contact our US team for
Europe contact our UK team and for China
and Japan please contact our Hong Kong
or Japanese teams respectively before I
hand you back the cake for any questions
you might have
I'd like to thank you for your time and
wish you all the best with your research
Thank You Augustine so I've had a look
at a few of the questions that have come
in
while the presentation has been which
has been given and I'd like to go
through a few of those with you now so
Petra has contacted us and asked if
there are any differences between PBS or
tedious for doing ICC Aria and how to
choose between one or the other
PBS estate at the same line is usually
absolutely fine for a Minnesota
chemistry TBS has a higher salt
concentration and it gives a more
stringent wash so perhaps if you're
having problems with any high background
you may want to change to PBS
laura has contacted us and said can you
incubate with your secondary antibody
for too long yes the course is possible
and you with me to optimize the length
of time that you incubate with your
secondary antibody we would recommend
that with 30 minutes to 1 hour if you
incubate too long you might start
getting some background but also of
course what is important is the
concentration and the dilation that
you're using the antibody out Jose has
asked if it's necessary to do the
nonspecific blockage for all antibodies
we would recommend to include a blocking
step it can sometimes be possible to
omit the bottom step and still get good
results but we would recommend to still
include that Jerry has asked is the
fixed size can be stored in 70% alcohol
at room temperature indefinitely to be
honest I wouldn't recommend to to do
this once you fix ourselves is better to
dry them and then keep them stored in
the dark at 4 degrees tathiana has
contacted us and said if I fix the cells
with organic solvent I don't need any
permeabilization is this correct yes
that is correct
um usually you don't need any further
permeabilization of these you
organic solvents just a couple more
questions for me for you here
so from Anushka we have we have a cell
line growing in suspension
I would like to use ICC for detection of
insulin receptors in these cells how
many sales do you recommend to spin onto
each side and at what speed so we would
recommend to start with cell suspensions
not more than about 5 times 10 to the 5
cells per mil you can check this for the
cell count and you can dilute the cells
with Culture Media if you need to for
most I system models you would place
about 200 microliters of suspension into
each side to spin and spin about 800 rpm
for 3 minutes
so number for Saito spinning will
probably need to be optimized because
different cells are different sizes and
I'd also check the instructions that
come with the slightest thing you have
for more information our meds has asked
I have an H 3t3 cells from Mouse and the
only primary we can find for detection
of our target protein is the mass
primary would this work generally
cross-reactivity of venality mass
secondary the Vesey receptors and
antibody was in the cell culture is not
something to be too concerned about in
icc but it does very much depends on the
cell line that you're using so for
example FC receptors on macrophages or
plasma cells these cell lines that make
it quite difficult but I'm not aware
that there would be any expected
difficulties when these particular cells
NIH 3 T 3 because they're fibroblasts
however if you did get a high background
then you could consider trying mass and
mass staining kits these just include an
extra blocking procedure to reduce that
cross reactivity we have several of
these available actually one example is
the one two seven zero five five that's
a B one two seven oh five five and there
are others as well there are two other
options here
you could try Anki basing the sections
with an unconscious ated fa b fragment
anti-mouse itv and buddy
for example incubate at one hour or
overnight and that will block your FC
receptors and another option is to
directly link your primary antibody to a
conjugate in this case so that you don't
have to worry about that secondary
antibody cross-reactivity we have a lot
of conjugation kits available now
they're called easy link conjugation
kits if you wanted to look them up